what I'm going to talk to you about
today is this idea that I've been kind
of working for the past couple of years
of like how can we really extract
information about biological systems
using these machine learning models and
so I just want to tell you a bit about
my background and so I'm a grad student
at Cal Tech and I mean the biophysics
program but I'm actually originally from
Mexico and so I was born in Cancun and
then I did my undergrad over here and in
mérida and I also worked at unum with
with a professor called Ernesto Perez
Arella
so we were really studying things about
these gene networks well I was in my
undergrad I had the chance to go to
Madrid for six months to study also
about biochemistry and biophysics and so
around this time there was a point where
we started to learn about the kind of
history of artificial neural networks
and we learned things about for example
the Caufield Network and like how simple
computations can actually generate the
learning process and so just out of
curiosity does anyone here has a biology
background at all yeah okay great that's
that's awesome and what are the other
backgrounds do you have like you can
just shout it out and I'll just physics
Industrial Engineering Thanks sorry
good Lassa fee awesome well that's great
yeah like I like to have like kind of
mix yeah kind of backgrounds but just to
kind of get a sense of of where I can
direct the talk so yeah like out of
curiosity do does any one of you know
who this guy is
well this was given that we were in PI
data and we have learned a lot
of neural networks today is so this guy
is Donald Hebb and he was one of the
pioneers in artificial neural networks
and kind of the ideas that have had was
that learning could be made but by a
very simple process in which certain
groups of neurons can like associate
themselves into like these clusters and
so like you know like computation or
like memory and stuff like that can be
triggered by just having a activation of
a subset of a given group of neurons and
that's kind of the theory of associative
learning and and with this in mind is I
started to think about the there were
like a lot of analogies with how neural
networks and how gene networks actually
work and so just also out of curiosity
do you guys know who who this guy is
well yeah it's as I was just kidding
yeah so kind of the the idea of this
talk the the central point is is kind of
this kind of this approach that where
that is just saying that how can we
learn the wiring of these genetic
networks that are actually controlling
how cells how cells behave basically
using machine learning and so this idea
is actually not that not that no in the
sense that it has been widely known that
genes that are wired together they most
likely fire together in the sense that
for example if two genes are correlated
in their levels of in their amounts in a
given cell they're most likely part of
the same process right and so this idea
is will be the kind of core of what we
will do today during the tutorial and so
just to give you a sense of what we're
going to do today is just to highlight
that again we're going
to use this knowledge that we already
have from biology that is a gene
regulatory networks and specifically we
will then train a machine learning model
and then we'll try to go back and to
kind of create this feedback between
these these two these two kind of
networks really and so I just want to
make a disclaimer at this point that
this kind of approach is not the end of
the story and so to me as a scientist
really what we're trying to do is trying
to understand how living systems work
and in order to do this
this approach is just kind of just
another tool that will finally well
ultimately guide us to like make
experiments and actually learn about how
how these complex systems that are that
are really biological systems actually
are what are what are the causal
relationships and the generative
processes that actually trigger this
this stuff and so biology really demands
quantitative models and this
quantitative understanding can only
really guide us through really grasping
this these that we are facing and just
to give you an idea of this remarkable
complexity I want to use ourselves as an
example and so in those humans there are
about six billion letters of DNA in each
and every one of our cells and so if you
actually think about it like just like
the sheer and utter complexity that that
makes us ourselves is really encoded in
this this idea of the chromosome and if
you think about the chromosome it's like
this big structure inside the cell that
has like three dimensional
to it and has a certain architecture and
so certain genes will be more in the
outward layers of the chromosome and
some will be actually hidden and will be
only activate at certain at certain
parts of development and so forth and so
if you think about the chromosomes it's
really it's really this idea of how how
complex actually genes genetic
information is encoded in the cells and
so also I want to ask you um yeah like
do you guys think that that the cells in
your brain and the cells in your heart
for example are the same oh well better
said the the genetic material that
that's in your brain cells and in your
heart cells is it the same yeah right
and kind of this this idea it's very
it's very interesting but actually what
gives each cell its identity is how much
of each gene is is present at which cell
and this kind of cell fate is it's
normally kind of chosen at development
but really is this kind of the
underlying control that makes this
really happen is these genetic networks
and so we can think of the cell identity
as kind of the wiring in which this in
these genes are connected to each other
and so before I get into more details of
of genetic networks for you to get kind
of a background on it I just want to
talk to you about a bit of how how genes
are made in the cell and so this kind of
like high school biology so and again
like if you don't come from a biology
background on don't feel bad because
actually this this diagram is wrong well
what is not wrong but it's at least not
complete isn't it's not a complete story
but this is just to give you a flavor of
how the basic idea of
genetic information kind of flows in the
cell and so we can think of this this
kind of software if you want to think of
it about it that way as it as agent of
other genes right and so the DNA is kind
of the software in the cell and then
this software has to get kind of
transformed into a protein which will be
the actual hardware that will make make
up the cell and so interestingly in the
early 2000s when scientists were trying
to read the human genome for the first
time we thought that after reading all
of the genetic code like that is the all
of the letters that are written in our
DNA we will get kind of the whole
understanding of the human genome right
and so actually what ended up happening
is that we found out that only 2% of the
of the letters in your DNA actually ends
up getting into a protein and so this
leaves us with like a huge amount this
98% of stuff that is kind of these
non-coding regions of the of the of the
genome and it's really interesting
because we're just about getting to
understand what is going on in this in
this part of the genome because
sometimes people think or people thought
that it was like this junk DNA but it's
really not the case and so I won't get
into the details of that but just to
give you an ascent of like this here
another complexity that we're facing as
biologists and that we really have to
use like this kind of a motivation of
why should we use these machine learning
tools to really extract information as
we can and so this is not only the case
of complex organisms such as ourselves
but this also happens in simple things
like bacteria and so besides being able
to read DNA we can also write it right
now and so this is just a diagram of the
kind
process that was taking place when
scientists made the first synthetic cell
and this was done just a couple of years
ago at the John Craig venturi and this
diagram is just saying that you start
with a sequence of DNA sometimes it was
a template in this case was a bacteria
and so you then kind of make certain
variations to it and kind of the end
goal was to make a what was in concept
minimal cell so what are the minimal
genes that one needs to put into a cell
that will actually live and reproduce
okay and so what they did is they made a
bunch of combinations and ended up with
a with a with a final minimal cell and
what was most interesting about it and I
just want to give you a flavor of this
what I like to cause biological
mysteries is that despite that they have
a recipe to make a completely synthetic
cell made of chimeric chemical
constituents almost twenty percent of
those genes like scientists have no idea
we had no clue of what these genes were
calling for we know there were essential
because if you took it took them out of
the cell of the recipe you wouldn't end
up with a fully baked cake but in a
sense we didn't really know what the
ingredients were in the first place
and so this I think this is very very
interesting and so what I want to claim
now is that if we have kind of the
wiring of how these genes are connected
to each other in this synthetic cell we
could have really have more of an idea
of what is really going on with this
so-called unknown or hypothetical genes
okay and so I just want to switch gears
back to this idea of genetic regulation
right now and so kind of the main actors
that are really controlling
how the wiring takes place in the cell
are these proteins that are that I
really love they're called transcription
factors and the story of these proteins
is that they actually love DNA they just
are always trying to bind DNA and you
know like do their thing and these
proteins are composed of two modules so
one module as I've said is a DNA binding
domain this basically and sorry there
will be like a bit of technical jargon
so if you guys have any question at some
point like please just like stop me or
raise your hand whatever because yeah
like I'm kind of biased in the sense
that I'm assuming that some of the words
you you will kind of understand but I
really want to get the message across
and so as I was saying these proteins
are composed of two modules one is a DNA
binding module and the other one is like
so called sensory domain and this
sensory domain is kind of kind of
receiving signals from the cell either
they could be chemical chemicals such as
metals or they can also sense pH for
example or high temperatures or whatever
and this will dictate when they will
bind to the DNA and control gene
expression and if we go a bit into the
abstract for the kind of engineers
physicists and computer scientists in
the room we can abstract these
interactions into directed Network and
so here I'm just showing you this
transcription factor that is controlling
a so-called target gene and so then
these these interactions can can exert a
certain function in the cell and so for
example what we like to call generic
circuits is this like these simple
relations that are made by a few a few
transcription factors and a few target
genes and they can for example elicit
for example an oscillator in the cell so
the circadian rhythm in in enough humans
that really drives when we are sleepy is
is basically control
by a generic circuit and then if we
could go to an even higher level of
complexity genetic circuits then form
gene regulatory networks and that's what
we're going to talk about today and
we're going to use a simple case study
that is that is kind of what I've worked
on for this past couple of years and is
bacteria's a simple model system for
studying gene regulation and
specifically we're going to use this lab
strain of bacteria that's eco like k12
and we will use this because there's a
lot of known information about it and
it's publicly available and moreover
we're going to use a as a case study
like even more specific like this
biological process of how purines there
are certain molecules they actually make
up DNA how purines are controlling the
cell and so purines interestingly
because they're essential to making DNA
they were really creative in early
stages of evolution and so this is a
very important protein that is called
pure are very important protein
throughout throughout the bacterial
Kingdom and we're going to use it as our
case study for today and so what we want
to really do is to learn how the gene
activation patterns of this protein is
encoded into into a cell and what we're
going to use as our data set is this so
called
RNA seek data that allows us to quantify
how much of each gene is made in the
cell and so here this RNA seek is just a
kind of term for RNA sequencing and so
basically the idea is that we can read
how much RNA is is produced in in in a
cell and so here in this graph I'm just
showing you a plot of two genes and in
different expression conditions and so
in this case is just like
an idealized example of of two genes
that are correlated and what I want to
also say is that this is not always the
case and there are very highly nonlinear
interactions in the cell that are not
really of this sort but yeah we will use
this data set to in the end do do this
we're going to take the gene regulatory
network we're going to build a binary
classifier to predict if a given gene is
inside the this purine module or if it's
not okay so that's kind of the the idea
of this tutorial and so yeah so let's
let's just go straight to it so this is
the link for the for the github repo and
if you guys just click this or type bit
do /pi de la you will go directly into
the repo or you can just yeah write it
completely so as I've said if you go
into the repo you'll you'll find this
this collab and bind their badges if you
click on it I will use collab just just
to be with
because there are some changes that have
to be done in the in the code so yeah if
you're in collab you just have to
uncomment this first couple of lines so
it's everyone and the notebooks already
everyone ready okay so in this first
just to give you a sense of what we're
going to do first we're going to first
extract the information from these
purine metabolism simple gene network
using publicly available data so first
I'll just it will tell you - oh yeah
sorry
so it will do its thing install some
libraries and stuff so the first thing
we're going to do is that we're going to
take data from this website I will open
just to show you while this is loading
this website called regulan DB that is
kind of a database of of e.coli and here
in downloads you can actually see this
if you go to experimental data sets so
if you're interested later on like
continuing this this this sort of
analysis there is a bunch of data that
you can actually download so for example
the sequences the genetic sequences the
genes the gene regulatory network and so
on and so forth so it's a very so-called
very cool so-called knowledge base of E
coli biology and so we're going to use
this data and this was this is this
website regular on TV is maintained by
the Colo lab at Nam and there are other
kind of databases if you so what I want
to show you today is kind of this
principle that we can take data set and
turn it into like machine learning model
using biological data I mean and so
there are other so called mojo bases for
example for bacillus subtilis that is
another bacteria for the worm C elegans
and and so on you can also find data
from from humans if you want there is a
bunch of data out there so
I just will uncomment this and this is
only for the people that is running in
in Google collab it's almost there
but yeah so what we're going to do first
is we're going to load this generic
network of e.coli and so if we look at
just the first five rows of the data set
you can see that there is this column
called TF that is the transcription
factor the regulator the target gene
this TG
there regulation type if it's repression
or or if it's an activation mechanism
and other things like the evidence and
so forth and so the first thing we're
going to do after is we're going to turn
this pandas dataframe into a network X
graph and so we will just use this
command from pandas h list and it
literally just takes a panda's data
frame and kind of the the columns that
represent the wiring of the network and
so one of the ideas that one might ask
is that well what is the kind of
organization of this network like we
don't know anything about Ecola biology
and we want to know how is it organized
well one thing that you could ask is who
are the main actors in this network who
are the main controllers or so-called
hubs and so we can we can do this by
just calculating the centrality measure
that is basically getting the hops and
so this is a method in in network X
called the eigenvector centrality and so
if we print the first the first ten hops
we will see that all of these genes pop
out and the record corresponding
centrality measures and and so these
these genes actually are transcription
factors and they're also called
Global transcription factors and so this
global transcription factors are
basically master regulators of gene
expression in the cell and in the sense
with just a couple of commands we can
start getting important information
about the architecture and the also kind
of the hierarchy of this network and so
yeah if we actually sort this this
dictionary we will actually get the
highest-scoring
global regulators okay and so yeah now
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the initial data frame and just get
which alike from the from the
transcription factor column which have
the more counts in the in the data set
and what we'll see is that for example
CRP is the one that has more
interactions and this is the one that we
actually end up seeing as a top hub in
the when we try to calculate the
centrality measured now let's let's go
ahead and start exploring this more in a
visual way and before we what we want to
do this kind of plot the network to see
kind of its architecture and so first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to extract the largest connected
component because you could imagine that
in this in this kind of graph there will
be some kind of islands that will be
just hanging around there we just want
to get the largest connected component
that is the biggest part of the of the
network that is completely connected and
that's what we're going to use as our
visualization scheme and so there is
this simple simple command from Network
X also that is based on math we'll leave
that we can just just call directly on
the graph
object and yeah we will get a plot of
the of the whole network okay so this is
kind of cool and so what we can see is
from this is that it basically is kind
of this exploding football and one thing
to notice for example is that there are
these genes that are kind of making
these these ramifications and so this
these I assume that these are actually
transcription factors that are
controlling a subset of for example a
metabolic pathway okay and so yeah kind
of the structure of biological networks
in general is that they have a so-called
scale-free scale-free structure and that
is that a lot of nodes have very few
connections and few notes have a lot of
connections and these this a small
subset of nodes that have a lot of
connections are the are the hubs and
moreover these networks organizes into
into groups and so we like to call them
clusters in biology and so is this kind
of two properties the scale-free
property and also this clustering
natural clustering that happens in
biological networks okay and so the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to plot how many interactions each node
have and so this is kind of abstracted
in the degree distribution and so for
for each node we will get how many
interactions it has in the network and
we will use the this library called
bulky cat lot which is which was made by
a professor at Caltech called just in
Boise and and the nice thing about this
this library is that it allows you to it
allows you to visualize categorical
distributions
in a very nice and interactive way using
bouquet and so first we we will make
this helper data frame because it uses a
data frame as a source tidy data frame
and so here he would just have the the
name of the gene which is the note and
the degree distribution and if it's a
transcription factor or a target gene
and so we can just go ahead and use this
library and we will make a straight plot
and we will separate the notes by either
transcription factor and target genes
and what you can see is that basically
if you if you zoom in you can see the
annotation of of each note and so you
can see the the gene name and yeah
whether it's a target gene and so forth
and you can see that the target genes
just make this cluster in like they have
very few very few connections and
transcription factors are actually just
having a lot of connections which is
kind of what we would expect and if you
kind of draw a hard boundary above 100
that's that's what I will call the
global master regulators and so all of
these genes actually called for global
transcription factors and if you're
interested just a subside notes we will
get into that but you can use for
example this website called eco psych
because at this point you might think
okay well but what what is this gene in
the first place like I don't even know
so let's just use CRP for example and
with this it will it's kind of like a
Wikipedia of e.coli and so you will see
the gene kind of what it does and yeah
you can get a lot of information out of
it so yeah if you're interested in just
like finding out more about this data
set there's like a lot of information
out there
in eco sake okay and so what we can see
is that okay we're already kind of
extracting the kind of the structure of
this Network we've seen that there are
very few genes that are actually
controlling most part of the network the
so called master regulators and and yeah
if we actually wanted to visualize it in
a more interactive way this graph we
there is this library called HB plot
that is kind of a higher level
functionality than coal abuse and there
is a network X module that we can use
and it's really really high level and
it's really amazingly awesome and yeah
we can visualize the network in
interactive plot and we can just hover
around every node and see which gene is
connected to and so forth I don't know
if this is taking a lot or yeah it
probably probably doesn't work in in
Google collab but yeah if you run it
locally you'll find out that is is
basically the same visualization as
before with matplotlib but it's
interactive alright so at this point one
another interesting thing is kind of
exploring this clustering of this gene
regulatory network and so we can just
use directly the graph that is the
connections to kind of extract the
clusters in it the natural clusters that
appear in the network and so there is
this algorithm for community detection
in in networks called a low vein
algorithm and it's implemented in this
Python library
community and so we can just import it
and they method to to call it is called
best partition and so in this object
it's already you can already see the
kind of the clusters that we have oh
[ __ ] I mean I think this is a dictionary
sorry
yeah and so we can extract how many
clusters we have for example in this
network and yeah we have 16 clusters so
after extracting the clusters I know
this is very abstract but we can map
back the clusters to the network and so
we can also use this set node attributes
method from Network X and we just give
it the network we give it the mapping
that is communities the clusters and we
will name this as modularity and then we
we can iterate over the nodes in the
network to get the cluster of each node
and we will then store this into a list
so this kind of a convoluted list
comprehension but in the end what we'll
have is just for each for each node
which cluster it belongs to and so for
example in this cluster we have a bunch
of genes and we can then just go back to
eCos I can see which functions are
encoding and yeah and so this does it
little exercise that I'll leave for you
later if you're interested and so so
there is this other data set so we took
the whole gene regulatory network of
e.coli what we can also get only the
interactions that are from the
transcription factors and so this you
can download directly from regulan DB in
this called tftf interactions
and so kind of the the question that I'm
posing here is just if you want to
cluster only the T of T of network that
is the kind of central control in this
in this organism you can actually do so
pretty easily with the code that we
already written and so okay now the the
the main part so what we actually wanted
to do from this network is just extract
the purine metabolism genetic Network
ret and so we'll just simply filter over
the data frame that we had in the
beginning just extracting the
interactions that are encoded for this
pure our protein so we do that here and
then we're just going to check how many
how many genes are controlled here and
we can see there there are 31 for
example you can see here and so all of
these target genes are being controlled
by the pure are transcription factor and
then we can say this say this as a CSV
but it's already in the github repo so
you don't actually have to do it and
then you might think well then how are
going to even make our training and test
set in the first place or how can we
really know if we are actually
predicting something that is
biologically relevant well the nice
thing about this is that there's this
other study by the Paulson lab at UCSD
that has already done this thing
experimentally so we will use that as
our kind of gold standard and see if we
can actually get the same results that
they got experimentally using this
machine learning model and so if you're
in Google collab you also have to
uncomment these lines
okay and so it's it's basically the same
structure of the data set you have the
transcription factor and the gene that
is being regulated by it and if it's an
activation or repression and so we're
going to do the same we're going to
filter out only the pure in gene Edward
that is also called regulan so if you
hear me saying regulan it means gene
Network and yeah we're also going to
save this save this as a data frame and
we'll be good to go and that is going to
be our training and test set okay cool
so now does anyone have a question up to
this point yeah um yes so yes so we will
get into that in in a moment so one one
idea that we will use is that we will
use over sampling to enlarge the data
set so kind of learn the distribution of
this a small subset and then use that as
our training what is a good question
so yeah that's kind of the idea like we
have a lot of negative we'll have a lot
of negative examples that are genes that
are not inside this sub network of
purine metabolism like you can have
genes that are coding for the cell
membrane that is making fatty acids or
genes that are making amino acids or
genes that are making I don't know DNA
repair or whatever and yeah that's why
we're going to have to use over sampling
so let's go to the second notebook
and so this is where the where the core
of this tutorial is will take the
expression data set and we will train
our our model using the wiring that we
just extracted so if you're in you're in
Google collab also you have to uncomment
these lines
and so while this is loading I can I can
tell you a bit about this data set and
so this data set was also published by
this pal song lab at UCSD and basically
the data set contains in each row it's
it's a matrix and so in each row it's a
gene so in the e coli genome there are
about four thousand genes so there are
like four thousand rows and then the
columns in the data set
represent different experiments so they
grab a coli they made a culture of it in
a big flash and so forth and then they
started making perturbation so for
example they grew in different sugars so
they feel ecoli with different sugars or
they deleted a gene and see what
happened to it and yeah there are like
about 50 expression conditions in
duplicates and so this is kind of the
structure of the data set is basically
each column represents an experiment of
the expression of all the genes in
different conditions and then the basic
units of like the entries is in this
measure called transcriptor million and
it's basically a proxy of how much of of
a given gene was made into RNA
yeah and so this this was a very cool
paper so here I'm leaving you the link
so while this loads I'll just talk about
a bit about the paper so they were also
interested in this idea of like unknown
genes and so remember I told you that
that in this synthetic cell about 20
percent of the genes we really have no
clue about what they were doing well
even in simple e.coli that we will do we
have been studying it for more than I
don't know 50 years a lot more than that
there are about thirty percent of the
genes that we don't have a clue of what
they're doing in this cell and so a lot
of this is just a lot of problems in and
in like database information and stuff
and so what basically why they do what
they did
in this in this paper was just just
trying to extract information from
different databases and kind of making
making everything into like this
comprehensive thing and one things that
one of the things that they found is
that basically these genes that we
haven't really discovered it's because
they're present in very little amounts
in the cell so they're really not
causing the phenotype that we can
actually measure and so that's one of
the ideas that they have into why why is
this this thing so difficult in the
first place okay so let's just go ahead
and and load the data and just look at
the at the shape so as I've told you
they were like a little more about 4,000
genes and if we look at the first five
columns first fiber oh sorry
we'll see that there is a column of this
annotation called local stack that is
basically just an IV for each gene then
we have the gene name as I've said each
row represents a gene and each column
represents for example here they they
they grew the the wild type that is the
kind of the normal eco light in glucose
then they did for example a mutation and
so forth and so these are just a bunch
of expression conditions for example
different like they put some acid and
see what happened to the cell and so
forth and so this is kind of the
structure of the data set
oh [ __ ] okay and so here I'm just going
to make a copy of the data set and then
I'm going to take the first two columns
there is the locust tag and the gene
name and then we're going just to take
the actual numerical values as this data
sub data frame and so first things first
we're going to normalize our data set
using a simple Stern the standard scalar
and then we're going to see if there are
any null entries or null values in our
data set
and so here we can see that it's just
like a mean of zero and a standard
deviation of one this is just a C score
and yeah we see that there is no missing
entries so we're good to go
so the next thing is just loading the
data sets that we generated in the in
the last notebook to start making our
annotations for the for the output of
our classifier
right sorry I you just have to add
quotes on this URL and same thing for
here sorry about that
for the Google collab are alright so we
have our datasets loaded and yeah we
have inner in our genetic network there
are 4,000 notes yeah
yeah so this the samples are actually
the the genes and the features will be
the expression conditions so in the last
visualization was just like kind of
transposing the so in the presentation
that I show you like the scatter plot of
the genes I just made a kind of a
transpose of that not in this case but
just to make the visualization we'll get
into that but yeah so it's a good
question but yeah basically the samples
will be our genes and the features will
be different expression conditions yeah
all right so just remember we have 31
nodes in this pure R sub Network and so
what we want to do is we want to get the
target genes there is the genes are
controlled by pure R and we'll just
extract that as a non P array so from
from the from the data frame that is of
the pure R sub network of regulan DB
we'll take the target gene column and
then we're just going to take its values
so you just have to for the guys at
Google cause using Google collab okay so
most of them okay so you just have to go
to the repo okay and then under the data
folder you will find this high tier and
csb so I think that's the one that we're
missing yeah exactly right Thanks
so you just have to change this URL and
basically put the height here and one
thank you for the one who noticed all
right so we should be good to go so you
have to put this URL pure our our DB
variable under this read CSB command do
you guys see and so now we should okay
and yeah so as we knew there are 31
target genes and we can also see this
just like to see like the actual gene
names so all of this and if you look for
example these other proteins called pure
a pure B pure C this is like the like
the set of genes that are actually
making the synthesis of purines and this
other peer are the ones that are making
pyrimidines that are other molecules
that make DNA and so in this sense this
this is just to give you a flavor of the
of the actual genes that we are handling
here okay so now we should be good to
then take from the Paulson data set that
will be our test set and we're just
going to basically get the set
complement of of the intersection of
these two of these two data sets just to
get the the genes that were discovered
by the pass on lab so this is are the
genes that were the we're going to try
to predict effectively using our machine
learning model so is everyone following
me at this point is there any question I
see kind of
everyone good all right and so now I
just want to give you more of a sense of
how how is this data set actually
composed and so what we're going to see
is this just very simple scatter plots
between the genes and so this is kind of
what I show you in this lights before
and yeah we're going to just take all of
the genes that are inside the our test
set these these five genes and we're
going to plot them against pure art with
the idea that if they're kind of
correlated then we might expect some
some biological relationship and so here
I just made a simple wrapper function
that basically extract the data for
these given genes and then makes a
seaborne scatter plot with with a the
Pearson correlation coefficient embedded
and so we're going to loop over the the
genes and then we're going to make these
these plots okay so as you can see some
of them are like for example this one
called peer I it is very it does doesn't
look pretty much correlated right but
there there are others like for example
champey this this is for another gene
that codes for the synthesis I think of
another molecule called Shanta seen and
this other important molecule in the
purine pathway and so we can see that
this is more correlated and stuff like
that so now what I want what I want to
do is just use the simple principal
component analysis to kind of use this
as a noise reduction technique
and so the basic idea is that we're
going to grab our data set then we're
going to project it into a latent space
that has 80% of the variance of the
whole data set and then in this sub in
this subspace then we're going to
convert back to our original
dimensionality and you will see that
actually these these forces the data set
to become more correlated and so yeah if
if you guys are interested in seeing how
these kind of words I leave this link to
a very nice blog post so yeah let's just
go ahead and do it
so we're just going to call this pca
object and so just to get a sense of
kind of the dimensionality of our data
set here we can see that we're gaining
like in just a few dimensions we're
getting most of the variance 90% of the
variance and so we can see that this
this data is actually very low
dimensional so just by taking the first
five components we get actually 94% of
the variance so we're going to use that
we're going to project into this just
four dimensional sorry five dimensional
subspace and then we're going to convert
back to do this noise filtering
procedure so in this sense we just
transform into the subspace and then we
convert back using the inverse transform
method and we can see that yeah we go
back to the same dimensionality and then
then I'm just going to just going to add
the annotation to this reconstructed
data set at the annotation of the
genomes to this reconstructed data set
and that's why we were going to work on
and so now if we do the correlation
plots again and if you go back and
compare we will see that actually this
we're forcing the the suspect because
we're actually projecting to this this
off a that has just like the most of the
variance in the data set we're forcing
the kind of reconstruction to have more
covariance between the between the
features and so yeah you did it just to
show you that this is this is just going
to be a kind of a noise filtering
technique that we're going to use all
right so to continue let's just
visualize how our dataset looks in the
PCI space oh no all of this is not
working in them this is not working in
in Cola I haven't noticed but then this
is so bad yeah it won't work but yeah
kind of the idea is that when you run it
locally if you want you will see that
there is basically this blob of of genes
and so what I want to claim is that
basically a nonlinear dimensionality
reduction might work better for purposes
of this highly nonlinear data set okay
so how are we doing there any question
up to this point we're almost almost
there guys almost there
alright let's just continue I'll just
take a deep breath
all right let's continue so yeah so now
we just have to annotate our training
and test data set to have like the
output of our classifier a subset so
this is just a wrapper function that
will actually extract extract data from
a data frame given a gene list so we
will use the list that we made before
from the pure are regulars from regular
DB and the Paulson data set and yeah so
before we do that let's just add this as
a one hot vector and so what we'll do is
is to say that if the gene is inside
this in this set of genes of the pure
our gene network we're going to put a
one and if not we're going to put a zero
so this is kind of the one code vector
and then we will add this one code
vector into our data set this noise
reduce data set so what we'll end up
with is this is this data set as before
just in the end we have this woo this
will take a long time but yeah in the
last column we will have the annotations
of if it's inside or outside our gene
network and so yeah we'll use this
wrapper function as I've said to just
extract the test set
so if you can see is just these genes
that we've already visualize champey
pure I pier B and so forth so we're
going to eliminate them from the
reconstructed data set and then because
we want to see also if the network
really finds out about the false
positives
that's just a sample from this from the
genes that are not inside the network
will sample without replacement you have
to make this kind of a noise and add
these to our test data set so in this
sense we'll make this kind of unbiased
test set and for the last notebook
remind me to use binder because I really
want to you for you guys to see the the
the interactive plots all right so now
I'll just make a copy of this unbiased
set and yeah we'll see that it has a
bunch of other genes that are not inside
the pure are regular and if you think
about it these genes might be inside the
the regulan because that's actually what
we're going to want to predict you see
it's like we're trying to match the
prediction the experimental predictions
of of this Paulson lab but if we wanted
to actually discover new genes we could
use this this model so we'll just use as
kind of a validation that the Metalworks
but these genes actually might be in the
regular who knows all right and then
just make this training subset just
making a copy of the other all right so
now we just have to split our data set
and
yeah just checking the dimensions that
we have we have 35 genes in our test set
and 4252 as their training and so yeah
just the output will be the last column
that I've set so here I'm just selecting
the the data and the output and it's
here is just checking that is this for
the training is just just numerical
values and for the for the output is
sorry for the X data set is just
numericals and Y is just a one hot
vector and so same for the test alright
and so last thing we have to do before
proceeding is for example if we look at
the training data as as he already
mention is like we have very few data
points of positive examples so we have
to do over sampling and so there is this
very nice library called imbalance learn
that has a bunch of implementations to
do over and under sampling so because we
have so few we will actually use over
sampling and there's this technique
called smote that is based kind of on
these K nearest neighbors it's kind of
making this data set using nearest
neighbors as a distribution sorry so we
will use this method to make the over
sampling and so with this simple simple
command we now have kind of a balanced
data set in order to make the training
and test alright
yeah so we can just try a couple of
models to see which one works best and
so just for now I want to say that we
will start with very simple models and
then kind of build up on complexity and
see which one works and which one
doesn't and so first we will use a
linear support vector machine and let's
see how how well how well it predicts
okay guys are you ready is this does
this thing work
alright well we can see that it's not
bad let's see at all the metrics yes I
would say it's pretty decent so in this
sense what we can see that yeah and if
we just look at with which are actually
yeah we basically get a pretty good
pretty good prediction I don't know if
this is an a gene that was actually in
the past on data set but we look pretty
good and so what I want to say now is
that at this point because this is a
perhaps very small subset of genes
simple very simple generic network I
will be happy to just continue just
doing hyper parameter tuning and just
keep this linear support vector machine
well they just try other other models to
see how how we have we roll so for
example if you is random forest
classifier
well edibles kind of like an assembler
model also so let's see
also not so pretty good kind of we were
kind of better with the support vector
machine so this might be what I what I
think is that this might be perhaps too
complex of a model for our data so it
might be actually overfitting our data
so in the sense that I will trust the
linear SVM but just to kind of do what I
promised and use some neural networks
this is let's just let's just use a
simple carrot model with one hidden
layer to see how well how will we do
yeah and there's this weird I think I
have a an older version of Kara's but
sorry yeah so just in the last step is
kind of 94 percent accuracy so yeah I
noticed this error in binary but yeah I
won't worry about that much so yeah I'll
just use some do some simple
cross-validation to make sure that the
support vector machine is actually doing
decent and so yeah it's pretty good
pretty good model so let's just wrap it
into a pipeline that basically takes our
training and test data set and just
scales the data and performs the
classification yeah and so at this point
if you want to how are we on time if you
want to actually these use this model I
think you can export it now and just
start started making predictions about
this simple genetic network okay and so
alright I think we have just a couple of
minutes right
fifteen minutes okay what do you guys
think like we can just take some
questions and talk for 15 minutes or if
you guys yeah yeah so or the other
alternative is just we can do a simpler
exploratory data analysis in a kind of
unsupervised way just to kind of get a
flavor of of the data set using non non
dimensional sorry nonlinear
dimensionality reduction let's just take
your question and see yeah you would
have to run those hundred and twenty
four so for a completely unknown
transcription factor you would have to
rerun the one hundred and twenty four
experiments there is a very very good
question actually and that is actually
the kind of basis of my thesis my
undergrad thesis and so yeah I think at
this point is there like one third of
the transcription factors that we really
don't know what they're doing but like
we know that it binds DNA and they have
a sensor domain and so forth and so what
we do is just a kind of fun unsupervised
learning the thing that we're going to
see next but yeah it's it's a very good
question and what I would say is that if
I understood your question yeah what I
would do is just stick to the
experiments to see kind of get get a get
a better flavor of what of what these
these genes are doing if you are going
into the machine learning world right
yes you can also find feature
importances so perhaps you could you
know find the most important experiments
to conduct right and get your decision
that's also another you know something
you could maybe look into wow that's a
great idea yeah no thank you this it's
it's really good yeah never thought
about it yes is this thing of like what
are the yeah exactly what you said like
what are the experiments that will give
the most information out of these
biological systems right I think that's
a very good question more questions or
ideas I don't know okay so yeah let's
just take this 15 minutes if that's okay
and if all our questions lies you can
just stop me
so I'll just switch to binder because
it's heavily visual this I don't know
how much this we're going to take yeah
this one is broken already
all right ah [ __ ]
yeah I think I tried it in binder so it
should work the weird thing is that Boca
cat blood did work so I don't know maybe
I messed up something with hobbies all
right so basically the idea here is that
is that biological systems are highly
nonlinear so for example evil even a
simple chemical reaction and enzymatic
reaction involves nonlinear parameter
and so in the sense I think that not the
nonlinear methods will really help us in
uncovering the structure of our data and
so here just make a rant of of what I
think about this in the biological realm
but basically the idea is that there's
this nice nice method called you map and
it's implemented super nicely in in a
library called you map learn and if you
want to get into the details I also
leave a blog post here but yeah let's
just go back and load the data and I'll
leave this thing running and keep on
talking and so basically the idea is
that you map will also find the kind of
like this manifold of that captures like
the global structure of our data set
and so in this sense we will just use
manifold in Ruby that makes any sense
and yeah we're we're going to then just
try to visualize visualize it if we get
some some structure out of it so here I
just add adjust these two dimensions to
our data set
and yeah let's see what we get
oh [ __ ]
is this weird kind of croissant haha
and so what is this actually telling us
about biology well I guess that we have
to find out like there is this there has
to be this hidden variable that's making
this variation right so yeah like one
idea is just like do some clustering on
the data and yeah you you might say that
well there's not any clusters in that
weird love but we'll just use clustering
to like actually extract the things that
are in the in the edges of this
croissant and we'll just use our
Gaussian mixture model to do it so this
should work in no time and the nice is
that the nice thing is that it's a
probabilistic model so we actually get
probabilities for each gene but we can
also get the most likely cluster that a
gene will will fall into and so let's
just quickly visualize it yeah and so
this is this kind of neat so we see that
cluster four is over here and I think I
thought this was going to have a
reproducibility to it but it seems like
it changes from batch to batch but yeah
basically the idea from here is to
extract the clusters in the edges and
see if there is like an enriched
biological function so kind of the the
idea if we have more time would be to
like go cluster from cluster and see
which function is actually enriched in
each kind of subsection of the latent
space and so these are not the edges but
let's just go with it
so we're just extracting in this example
cluster six and cluster 11 and together
in which biological functions you can
just use this annotation based thing
that it's kind of the golden standard
it's it's called gene ontology I don't
know why these wings so one database
that you can use is actually called
Panther and what what you input is just
a list of genes basically and it will
sorry this is you're not seeing this
right yeah you basically give a set of
gene names and it will output what
functions are over represented in the
data set so what I did is I downloaded
the annotations and I made like some
simple wrapper functions and so for
example in cluster six there is nothing
enriched and then in cluster 11 no luck
either oh god it's awful that changes
from batch to batch well I have no luck
in this time but basically you can go
clusters from cluster to cluster and I
made this like simple hyper geometric
test in this pie file that I'm putting
in the repo and you can see then in eco
psych just which genes are are like
getting more of a story of what you're
getting so yeah this this is this is it
I just want to I just want to thank you
for paying attention and just tell you
again that this was based on work that I
did in the Paris red lab at Medina and
yeah if you want to collaborate or or
just talk more about these ideas feel
free to reach out and yeah GRN stands
for a gene regulatory network
if you have okay so thank you guys